visage caché par peur d'éventuelles
représailles
ces deux étudiants en orthophonie se
sont confiés à nous à besançon elles
entament leur cinquième année d'études
est toujours le même la lettre c des
appels pendant les vacances
les jours fériés des mails à 4 heures du
matin pour un cours qui a lieu à 8h des
mails à 23h pour nous dire que
finalement on commencera plus tard le
cours qui a des mots qui passe mal il ya
des mâts bld tu comprends rien
vous êtes des quiches voilà des choses
qui n'ont pas être à dire ce sont
manipulés rabaisser on est vraiment
épuisé par la situation est vraiment se
sont
beaucoup d'intimidation a l'impression
d'être pris au piège vraiment un
sentiment d'incompréhension général en
fait on a quand même beaucoup
d'étudiants qui ont des troubles
alimentaires des troubles dépressifs
qu'ils prennent des anxiolytiques maître
de stage et enseignants ont tout résumé
dans une lettre écrite il ya quelques
jours on y parle de la détresse
psychologique des 150 élèves suivant
actuellement la formation et de ce
qu'ils ont terminée mais en souffrent
comme plusieurs députés ont même alerté
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
c'est désormais fini c'est à dire il ya
un côté psychologie si jamais dehors
quand on fait des études de psychologie
on est victime de harcèlement moi
comment voulez vous arrivez un
enseignement de qualité dont il sait
très important il faut le faire puis si
ça peut donner l'exemple à d'autres il
ya d'autres moments où nous fait des
pressions sur les étudiants qui sont pas
saines une partie de l'équipe
pédagogique dont le directeur de la
formation a récemment démissionné la
présidente de l'université quant à elle
a accepté de nous recevoir elle dit
prendre la sphère très au sérieux
quand vous avez un témoignage isolé vous
dites c'est des faits qui sont pas
obligatoirement important sauf que quand
vous avez une multiplication des
témoignages là vous rendez compte que
c'est très important
j'ai rencontré quand même dix étudiants
la confiance que les étudiants m'ont
fait fait que je sais que leur parole
est juste et et je les ai cru ce matin
une réunion s'est tenue en présence de
la direction et de l' agence régionale
de santé les faits ont été signalés au
procureur de la république et les cours
sont suspendus jusqu'au 14 novembre
inclus